[Music]
who you met what are you doing hey buddy
you just woke up from your coma
names Bunco the goddamn hospital clown
with the up bro where's my pills
yeah man sorry on a careers been deader
than David Bowie and Prince so ends the
medicine Prince and Bowie died oh yeah
that's right you don't know dick about
a lot of dumb I'd
while you were in that coma like the big
scary fish oh and the
Harrison Ford
don't care about character han Solo you
big han Solo fan oh man I hate spoilers
we also lost poor Zsa Zsa Zsa Zsa Zsa
Zsa Gabor the actress she was kind of an
actress she slapped that cop oh gosh
that's fine I thought you were doing all
Star Wars thing now I would never do
that to someone I'm not a nerd
hey Mel yeah bro get off my I'm
just up ever since Ringling
Brothers made the announcement that they
were pulling the plug on the whole
operation the Ringling Brothers yeah
why do you think I'm a hospital clown
hello clear hey can I get a light off of
one of those
you